il ya un petit verdun dans chaque
village et ceux verdun c'est le monument
aux morts ils portent la mémoire de la
première guerre 20 2824 monument aux
morts en france les enfants beaux jours
viennent jouer autour discuté cela sans
mélancolie avec un petit coup de pouce
financier de l'état les communes les ont
bâties rapidement après la guerre 94%
des monuments aux morts de la première
guerre ont été érigés dans les années 20
khz ainsi veille le bronze et la pierre
pour que ne s'oublie pas 14 15 16 17 18
bien souvent la statue d'un poilu tron
sur l'édifice et parfois ce modèle était
un soldat rentré du front comme monsieur
fromont dans le nord près de cambrai
c'était réellement fatigant
les poilus ont disparu mais les
monuments reste encore faut-il que la
commune en étant à cournon dans le
morbihan il a fallu attendre presque
soixante dix ans après l'armistice
oui bien sûr mais vous savez au
calendrier des héros les années ne
compte pas des décennies après leur
construction les monuments aux morts
font partie du patrimoine français
certains se visite comme anouar terre
dans les deux sèvres
presque un parc
depuis les années 90 les monuments aux
morts fascine les chercheurs cliniques
ouvert un champ d'investigation
inimaginables sur ce problème des
monuments aux morts
les emplacements les symboles tout a été
étudié les monuments aux morts en même
fait l'objet d'expositions la gloire des
héros tombés au combat mais aussi par
endroits l'opposition à la guerre ce
sont les monuments de paie moins austère
évocation de la tristesse de la peine
non
[Musique]